what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the tragic life of Eskin
or including his full backstory that has
just recently been revealed in chapter 3
27.5 of the manga and which ended up
being a 40-page Eskin or side story this
side story fills in a lot of the gaps in
esken Orr's backstory including how
exactly he met the rest of the sins and
how he decided to join the seven deadly
sins in the first place we also learned
more about Eska Norse connection to
Merlin and I believe that this Eskin or
side story actually offers some very
important clues about what is going to
happen next in the main story itself for
that reason I had to dedicate a full
video to the tragic past of s kannur and
how his conflicting personality and his
incredible power shaped him into the man
who he is today into the man who would
sacrifice everything for his friends
even when this might not be the smartest
thing to do if you enjoy the 7le sense
content on this channel please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications with the
way YouTube works now if you don't make
sure to turn on all notifications you
will definitely miss a lot of our videos
finally please be aware that this video
will be dealing with the latest
information we have about esken or in
his backstory so there will definitely
be some manga spoilers with that said
proceed with caution you have been
warned for quite some time we've known
bits and pieces about Eska Norse past
but now thanks to chapter three 27.5
we've finally gotten a more full account
of his backstory including how he became
a member of the seven deadly sins
ESCA North Side Story begins with him
detained and on trial in the kingdom of
Leonys he is charged with terrorizing
towns and villages beating up a bunch of
the holy Knights including sir Aras and
being arrogant and disrespectful towards
King Bartra by the way is that his
Excellency Lord Twigg Osama senpai
sensei himself next to the other holy
Knights did I or did I not tell you that
Lord we go we'll be appearing again in
the seven deadly sins story it was
written anyway s can
eventually sentenced to 1,000 lashes and
death for his crimes
apparently sentencing him to death was
not enough so they had to whip him first
since the trial is taking place at night
the man who has been sentenced is a
frail and scared looking nighttime Eskin
or the holy nights in attendance cannot
believe that this is the same man who
caused all that havoc throughout the
kingdom s kannur tries to explain that a
monster had been terrorizing the towns
and villages in question and he was
actually the one who defeated the
monster but because he was in his
massive daytime form at the time the
villagers thought that s Connor was a
monster himself and they were terrified
of him so they reported that he was a
monster
however in a sad turn of events even
though s Connor knows that he had been
unfairly charged he does not object he
says that the court should just kill him
but meliodas shows up and he objects
meliora stakes
s kannur to the headquarters of the
seven deadly sins where he introduces
into the other sins and he declares that
s Kannur will be the seventh and final
sin again because this is all still
taking place at night s Kannur looks
like an incredibly weak human with a
miniscule power level of 15 so bond king
and the other sins can't believe that
this is the famous seventh sin but
regardless of the fact that he appears
to be just an extremely weak human man
the oldest welcomes s Kannur into the
seven deadly sins as the sins introduced
themselves to s Canora and discuss their
various powers and abilities s Connors
current form seems very underwhelming by
comparison by the way I found it funny
how even at this point many years ago
King was totally in love with the end
and he kept acting all jealous about
esken or potentially staring at her
bosom you gotta respect Kings commitment
the man has spent decades in the
friendzone but he has now finally
emerged from his shell grown a pair of
wings and summoned the courage to
propose marriage to the end
very cool King very cool once Merlin is
introduced to s canora's the most
powerful wizard in Britannia s Kannur
notices right away that she looks a lot
like Rosa the woman who had helped him
escape persecution back when he was
still a child in his home kingdom of
Castelli oh by the way
Merlin's choice of eveningwear in this
is on point no wonder s Kannur fell in
love with her so hard when this is how
she welcomes him into the seven deadly
sins
Merlin remarks that she and Mellie Otis
had already met s Canora once before but
back then he was in his daytime form and
when they asked him to join the seven
deadly sins he just laughed at them and
turned away this was the scene that we
already got to see in the anime the
scene in which Merlin and Mellie Otis
come across s Kannur right after he
defeated an actual monster however even
though he defeated the monster in order
to protect the villagers the villagers
were still all scared of him because of
his immense power and arrogance and in
the end he ended up on trial instead of
getting a medal for saving everyone bond
is still confused about why as Connor
was chosen despite appearing to be so
weak so he starts pressing s kannur
about what his combat specialty is bond
is assuming that if Merlin and meliodas
decided to invite askin or to become one
of them he must have some special power
or ability that makes him a worthy
member of the seven deadly sins
but as Connor merely responds by saying
that his specialty is poetry which is in
itself pretty hilarious I mean that's
kind of like a new guy coming to train
with you for a heavyweight UFC
championship and when you ask him what
his fighting style is he just says
poetry then in classic seven deadly sins
fashion everyone decides to celebrate
that all seven sins are now assembled by
getting drunk but once the other sins
are fast asleep from the booze s can or
tries to run away as he begins to recite
a dramatic poem about his lonely
departure Merlin appears beside him and
asks him why he is leaving a surprise
desk Anor explains that the form she and
Mellie Otis had seen earlier his daytime
form is a curse that results in him
losing all reason and becoming strong
far beyond his control
s Kannur is afraid that if he stays with
the sins he will just end up hurting one
of them one day when he loses control of
his powers and he says that it would
have been better if he had never been
born or if he had died that day instead
of letting Rosa save his miserable life
at this point we really have to
acknowledge that s Kannur has lived a
hard and tragic life as much as this
younger nighttime s Canora appears to be
the polar opposite of the confident and
supremely powerful daytime eScan or that
we know and love we have to try and
understand s car's personality and where
his profound inner conflict is coming
from s can
is at his core a kind and sensitive soul
a poet and a romantic who doesn't want
to hurt anyone
nevertheless as a result of his immense
power a power that chose him and that he
inherited through no fault of his own
ESCA noir tends to lose control of
himself and he becomes incredibly strong
and arrogant during the day so much so
that he is capable of leveling entire
villages and mountains if he gets upset
askin or being the kind and sensitive
person that he is is profoundly afraid
that he is going to hurt innocent people
or even people that he cares about while
in his daytime form and Eska nor feels
that if he does end up hurting someone
he cares about he simply will not be
able to live with that tragedy on his
conscience he would rather die if that
means that he will no longer be a threat
to anyone then go on living and risk
hurting innocent people merlin tells us
kannur that he is really an interesting
man and this makes Eskin or blush Mele
ODIs approaches just as the Sun begins
to rise and he reassures a second or
that he doesn't have to worry the sins
are not weak and he doesn't have to
worry about hurting them in fact Mele
Otis invites a scanner to let him test
out his daytime strength but Eska Noir
is already beginning to transform and he
warns Mele Otis that if he comes any
closer
he can't guaranteed and Mele Otis will
survive but meliodas just laughs in his
classic millio de style and he
approaches esken or anyway in the very
next moment Mele Otis is sent flying and
he rams into bond and both of them
splatter against the wall daytime eScan
or freaks out and runs away he rushes up
into the mountains and starts smashing
one of the mountains with his fists
begging for someone to stop him and put
an end to his accursed life before he
hurts more people you can't help but
feel heartbroken for a second or at this
point he has to live with this power
that he didn't choose to have and this
power forces him to be alone all the
time
because most people are terrified of him
and those who are not terrified might
end up being hurt by him even if he
doesn't want to hurt them this is
killing a scanner on the inside because
he is not some ruthless bloodthirsty
warrior who loves to fight he is a
sensitive and kind-hearted poet who just
wants to live his life in peace once
night finally comes an exhausted and
miserable Eskin or is sitting alone by
the mountain that he had
been smashing Merlin approaches him and
Eskin or explains that this is why he
has lived his life in isolation from
others this is why he lives with utter
loneliness because everyone is afraid of
him when he is in his daytime form
everyone sees him as a monster and Eska
nor is constantly worried that he is
going to lose control and hurt someone
Merlin suggests that they should work
together in order to find a way to
control s converse power but s kanuri
surprised that Merlin would be so nice
to him after he just brutally murdered
two of her friends meliodas and bond
Merlin reminds s Connor of Rosa not just
by her appearance but also how kind and
nice she is towards him other than Rosa
Merlin is the only other person who was
ever nice to him and thought of him as
more than a monster
however as s kannur laments about how he
brutally murdered bond and Milly Otis
even though they were Merlin's friends
bond Emilio de show up and ask him what
he's talking about
at first asking are things that they are
ghosts and he wonders how they could
possibly still be alive malli Otis
explains that s Kannur is not the only
so-called monster around here every
member of the seven deadly sins is
considered strange and monstrous in one
way or another every one of them has
their own share of baggage and their own
sins s Kannur is still miserable he says
that he never wanted this power and the
curse always leads to him destroying
things and hurting people even his maid
Rosa the woman who had helped him escape
the kingdom was forced to become a
traitor and to put herself in direct
danger just to help him years after he
first left
esken or returned to the kingdom where
he was born but the entire kingdom was
destroyed by barbarians and Rosa was
nowhere to be found
Merlin then offers to use her magic to
allow s Canora to speak to RO some once
again but s Kannur says that he doesn't
want to because he can't even look her
in the eye
s Kannur is sure that she now hates him
because she went through hell because of
him and he says that Rosa would probably
be happier if he was dead at this point
bond has had enough he grabs a scone or
tells him to get a grip and basically
scolds him for just feeling sorry for
himself all the time instead of taking
control of his life Malley Otis decides
to bargain with Eska noir by inviting
him to have a match with him the next
day at noon the fight between them will
be a gentleman's wager if meliodas can
win the fight against Deskin or at his
strongest
then s Kannur has to agree to join the
seven deadly
since but if Eskander wins then he can
do whatever he wants and he can run away
from the sins if that's what he chooses
to do man Leodis and a scanner begin
their fight at high noon with Eska nor
in his colossal the one form s kannur
gains the upper hand at first pounding
the much smaller malleolus with his
massive fists but malleolus proceeds to
activate his demon powers he goes into
assault mode and he overpowers Eskin or
as he forces s Kannur down to the ground
he tells him that if he really wants to
die malleolus will snuff out his life
right there on the spot
s Connor is shocked that he can actually
feel pain even in his the one form and
melly Otis explains that he can feel
pain because he is alive and he is alive
because Rosa chose to protect him at the
risk of her own life s Connors life is
not his own thinking that his life is
not worth living is selfish and conceded
clearly Rosa thought that he was worth
saving and she was willing to risk
everything to save him so by constantly
sulking about his existence s Kannur is
actually dishonouring Rosa sacrifice
after malleolus finishes his speech s
Kannur says that yes he still wants to
live and he wants to speak with Rosa one
more time with Merlin's help meliodas
adds that if s Kannur ever finds himself
in a situation where he can't control
himself in the future malleolus will be
there to take care of that for him
essentially malleolus is saying that he
will stop esken or before he does
serious damage to himself or others and
this is an important point remember this
because I will return to it later
Merlin succeeds in reuniting s Kannur
with Rosa but they don't end up meeting
in Britannia
although s Connor doesn't seem fully
aware of where they are in reality
Merlin allows s Connors consciousness to
meet with Rosa in the afterlife inside
the capital of the Dead this confirms
that Rosa died sometime after a skinner
left his home Kingdom perhaps during the
barbarian invasion s Canora thanks Rosa
for protecting him all those years ago
and he promises to live his life to the
fullest in order to honor her sacrifice
s Canora promises to do the right thing
by Rosa no matter how lonely and awkward
he might be and Rosa tells him that he
has always done right by her and that he
doesn't need to feel alone anymore this
reunion is true
a heartwarming moment but it is also a
sad moment because s Kannur doesn't seem
to realize why Rosa hasn't aged and why
she has been watching over him this
whole time s Kannur doesn't seem to
realize that Rosa is dead nevertheless
he promises Rosa that even though he
almost abandoned this life he is now
going to devote his life to his precious
friends and now we know what promise s
Connor was talking about back in Chapter
three to seven it seems that he wasn't
talking about a promise he made two mile
or meliodas
which are the two options that I was
thinking of when I first read the
chapter rather he seems to be referring
to the promise he made to Rosa the
promise about dedicating his life to his
friends and this reinforces the
possibility that s kannur may be
intending to sacrifice his life for his
friends in the fight against the demon
king but if this is as Connors plan it
would go against the main lesson that
has been so prevalent in this side story
the idea that s can or cannot abandon
his life so easily that he must live on
in order to honor the sacrifice that
Rosa made for him so is this kind of
really about to push his body to the
breaking point in order to reach a state
beyond the one and defeat the demon king
is this decision going to actually cost
him his life in the end or is this kind
were going to survive thanks to the help
of his friends the sins remember'd a
scene from the Side Story that I talked
about earlier the scene in which
malleolus defeats a scanner and then
tells him that if he ever loses control
meliodas will be there to stop him from
going berserk and hurting himself or
others I can't help but think that this
might be foreshadowing for what is about
to happen next in the epic fight against
the demon king is meliodas going to
realize that s Kannur is pushing himself
too far and that he is about to die and
his meliodas then going to use his full
demon lord powers to knock askin or out
in order to save him from himself
s Connor seems determined to give up his
life for his friends but as we saw in
the side story s Connors friends don't
want s Kannur to die they want him to
live and I'm wondering if the only way
to stop asking her from overdoing it
will be to literally knock him out in
the middle of the fight against the
demon king we will have to wait and see
but to me the main message of the side
story is that s Kenard needs to value
his life more and that he needs to be
willing to rely on his friends he seems
to always want to protect others at his
own expense
but perhaps the wiser strategy would be
to work together with his friends
instead of sacrificing his own life in a
one-on-one battle with the demon king I
have to say that I truly appreciate Eska
nor as a character including the
dichotomy between his daytime and
nighttime personalities and the fact
that this power that he received through
no fault of his own the divine grace
sunshine might be a blessing in the
sense that it makes him probably the
strongest human who has ever lived but
it is also a curse because it condemned
him to a life of loneliness and misery
at least in the early stages of his life
before he met the sins on the one hand
we have a daytime Eskin or who says that
kings are as plentiful as grains of sand
but there is only one s Kannur and on
the other hand we have a nighttime s
Connor who doesn't even think that he
deserves to live at least at first
s canora's life has been tragic in so
many ways but the one bright spot in his
life has been Merlyn and the other sins
his precious friends he now seems
committed to sacrificing himself for his
friends and that may lead to the tragic
end of his life but I have a feeling
that his friends will step in and
especially manly Otis in order to stop
Eskin or from sacrificing himself
I certainly hope that s kannur survives
because after everything that we know
about his tragic past he deserves a
happy ending his plan might be to give
up his life for his friends
but I hope his plan fails or changes
because I want to see us gonna live and
to be completely honest I want to see
the relationship between s Cara and
Merlyn develop in the side story it is
implied that Merlyn is also lonely that
she has lonely eyes just like Rosa and s
Kannur we don't actually know a lot
about Merlin's past and we really need a
side story for her too in order to learn
more about her but I have always been
rooting for Merlin and s kannur to end
up together I think their personalities
would complement each other well and I
think that after living in loneliness
for such a long time they both deserve
to be happy together in conclusion even
though s Connor has led a tragic life
and even though there are clues to
suggest that s Canora might be about to
give up his life for his friends
I really hope that s Koerner will have a
happy ending rather than a tragic one
but let me know what you guys think is s
Kannur about to push himself too far and
die or is something else going to happen
let me know down in the comments I
always love hearing from you if you
enjoyed this video you want to see more
seven deadly sins content right here on
the
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest 7 Deadly Sins news
and updates including news about the new
season of the anime I want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime outpour
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thanks to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress on hell crews stealers
poet Pablo
atropos Wraith and fitty dalla beat and
also an epic thank you to all of ours
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
up up all other clans including Ingrid
ah a Lola Adam madam AK and makoto-kun
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron only discord and to show our
gratitude your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]